so the last thing I want to touch on is
obviously you've had a very public
battle with cancer yeah it's been going
on for how long I mean how long have you
been living with cancer now no I'm over
three years I think honestly the you've
handled it with like great grace and
optimism from from the very beginning
that's inspired me and first of all
thank you for for doing that okay and I
think it's been a beacon of light I
think for a lot of people of just like
seeing how you can handle it with with
dignity and I know that heelas dealing
with some her dad just got recently
diagnosed with cancer we were talking
about it backstage and it's really nice
to hear you being you know optimistic
about it basically well firt my first
question is cuz the last update that I
was able to find was from like June or
some show yeah how's it going or
whatever without that so basically where
we are right now is that it is
stabilized meaning it's not gone away
but it's not growing so there's a couple
of small tumors in my liver and there's
one very very small nodule in my lung so
it's Stage four which means it spread
past the initial place it was Stage four
was pretty bad that's when survival
chances go in the toilet oh no it's over
the 15th mm 17 2015 sorry I was told
you've probably got two years to live
that was two years and five days ago but
cancer yes oh [ __ ] those odds and [ __ ]
yeah but the problem with
metabolize cancer is the metastasize
cancer sorry it can go anywhere it gets
in the blood it can spread to any organ
becomes harder to nail it down you know
you can't do targeted therapies as
easily you can't just cut it out so it
being stable at this stage is very very
good because it means the therapy works
and it's continuing to work and I have
fairly minimal side effects still got me
beard still got me through I should I
mean you know you don't look like a guy
who has cancer yeah I love you I sure as
hell did you know there was a people
were asking I don't know if you'd know I
did a voice back for Starcraft 2 and the
photo they gave for me for that
was in black and white people like did
he die is that why they've made it black
and white but know who I look terrible
in that photo but it you know I the
chemo sucks
of course it sucks I have every two
weeks I got plugged in on the Wednesday
I get the big dose in the clinic and
then they put me on a portable thing to
take home for the rest of it until
Friday so I'm pretty much like out of
action for two days and then I test
about two days to really get back on my
feet you know what is that experience
like I feel like this conversation
doesn't exist anyway weeks and you're
managing to keep everything going
yes I mean one I don't see another
option you know it's like everyone has a
job you know it's you know my job so
huge motivator for me you know I'm proud
of what I do and I enjoy it and I know
that I'm very blessed to be able to do
it as a career right so I want to take
every opportunity I can to do it that's
why I'm out here with twitchcon that's
why I'm going to blows cards you know I
want to take joy in that and I get a lot
of satisfaction out of it and that also
means I want to be back on my feet as
quick as possible so you know I look at
it and I say right okay I've got ten if
I if I can get back on my feet got ten
good days and four bad days every two
weeks and you know what that's okay I
can rather have 14 good days but I can't
have 14 good day so I'll take ten that's
okay
and I mean the experience of actually
being on the therapy itself I mean it
essentially turns into a zombie it's one
of the best ways to describe it I mean
it's your whole body is in pain
I just constant aching there's a feeling
of sickness although that varies on a
person-to-person basis I get a subdermal
injection right here it's quite new they
only just started doing this and it's a
gel and it slowly goes into your
bloodstream oh it costs about five days
and it's an antiemetic so it's an
anti-nausea gel it knocked the nausea on
the head in a really good way like you
still feel a bit sick but I used to like
throw up like eight times at ten times a
day like until I was just throwing up
stomach acid that's gonna be it isn't
burned it was nothing but burning that
part of chemo has got to be really
difficult to the healing process right
yeah whole thing of knocks you okay yeah
because you get massively dehydrated
like that's the advice that I give to
anyone else to go through chemotherapy
two things one hydrate for the love of
God like drink fruit juice in particular
don't drink water drink fruit juice it
gives us yeah calories sugar really
important the taste will help you drink
faster in my case one of my side effects
is I have a cold sensitivity while I'm
on the pump so if I drink something too
cold it can shut my throat and kill me
oh my god yeah also if I just touch
something that's too cold
nice that kind of sucks so I've gotta
wear gloves and make sure you know
stuffs at room temperature before I
drink it but I found the like drinking
fruit juice I can drink it a lot faster
that means I can hydrate better and the
other thing is force yourself to eat you
threw it up [ __ ] you eat it again just
not the same thing obviously don't go
yeah just keep eating
dude like because it is fuel it
literally is fuel it's fuel to fight if
you give up on that everything gives up
but every time I eat even if I don't
like the taste of it I don't like the
feeling of eating it about ten minutes
after I've eaten or even as I'm eating
I'll feel this burst of energy like it's
like becoming awake again at least for a
couple of hours it's incredible to hear
that because I've been yeah all of us
who aren't sick we take food for such
granted right and also it's the most
basic thing that you can think of you
gotta feel yourself to continue right
it's so obvious until your body is
screaming at you not to mm-hmm and
telling you I'm gonna throw that up if
you do that and you just like no you're
not I'm gonna eat it and if I throw it
up I'm gonna cook another thing and I'm
gonna eat that
until something stays down because you
need those nutrition you need you need
that nutrition if you don't have it your
cover is gonna get longer or longer and
your your immune system is gonna just
collapse you know I have a surprisingly
strong immune system I should have no
immune system by now my immune system is
fine and it's taking a bit of a beating
but it's fine
a lot of people in my stage can't even
travel because it'll kill him you know
catch catch a cold he dead for me now
I've been fortunate in that they found
the right combination of drugs they
found a chemo that was unpleasant but I
could tolerate it and I've got a good
oncologist who knows what he's doing so
you know
we need him to do is keep giving me the
stuff that works and I'll keep fighting
it and I'll keep going and that's the
only option there is just to keep going
what other option is there you just give
up no there's nothing else nothing
beyond this mm-hmm you've got to fight
ten good days four bad days even if it's
one good day 13 bad days that's still
one good day do you find that you've
become more optimistic in some way since
your diagnosis was in some place like
it's hard to worry about petty [ __ ] when
you've got you know death staring you in
the face do you feel like you have some
knowledge that you wish you could share
like I know for example to use it mildly
you'll get a flu and you'll be like man
I can't [ __ ] wait til I'm not sick
again and then the moment you're better
you forget all about that is there some
kind of feeling that you're always
having like that that you wish you could
just [ __ ]
that you wish everyone could appreciate
and feel is that something a minute
think of chemo was getting over the
worst flu of your life and feeling like
you were not a real person while you had
it that sounds off like a zombie I even
trapped in your own head sometimes I
think about being so tired that you
can't watch Netflix it's too exhausting
that that's what it does to you and as a
result what you've got to do you get
trapped in your own mind I said yeah
even listening to things like audiobooks
it's like bright light sounds anything
any kind of stimulus becomes scary it's
you know you jump in at shadows it it
screws with your mind
it screws with your head in a big way
there's a fog paranoia it is a really
nasty thing to put in your body but
ultimately you got to do it and you got
to keep doing it if you want to actually
overcome it there's no easy way to do
chemotherapy there's no magical advice
but there is stuff you have to do it's
tough it helps to have someone close by
you helps to have someone like my wife
that will push me to do these things
that will say you've got away you've got
a drink I don't care what you think
eat the [ __ ] food having somebody
like that having that kind of support
system is essential
I don't think I'd be alive if I didn't
have that god bless her yep dude well
that's really inspiring oh it is what it
is you play the hand you're dealt you do
the best you can you don't give up on it
you know it's because it's not just
giving up on your life it's giving up on
everyone that's ever been touched by
what you've done your friends your
family pets for God's sake you know you
want to be there for them
like they deserve to have you there for
them the only way that that's going to
happen is if you keep fighting and it's
possible like [ __ ] these statistics they
don't mean anything if you don't like
the statistics change the stats now live
long outlive it just keep going because
science is [ __ ] amazing and they come
up with new stuff every day they come up
with new treatments all the time do you
think that chemo will be looked back on
and hopefully as soon as 10 years as
this like almost like how will you stay
electrocute people with illnesses well
we looked like as leeches only Bob yes
because we're killing the patient and
hoping the cancer dies faster right it's
not a great way to do things but it's
the best thing we've got right now
there's a general first line of defense
it's not the only thing and people
should be aware of that you know if
chemo fails for us I have a neighbor
she's had stage 4 cancer for 20 years
that's he's currently doing
immunotherapy brand-new immunotherapy
she's doing really well on it like the
tumors are shrinking she had cancer all
over her body you'd be shocked by what
is out there or what is being developed
right as we speak that's awesome and all
you got to do as someone that has it is
to give those guys a bit more time give
them as much time as you can give them
and that means putting in your effing
surviving all right all right simple as
that really
is there a organization that we can
donate to that you in particular hi
holding high interest that's worthy of
people's money I mean there's quite a
few I what you got to watch out for with
cancer in particular there's a few that
are not a good idea like I always get
upset in October because it's Breast
Cancer Awareness Month and
a lot of the companies donate to Susan
Susan G Komen right which is a terrible
organization they they waste money on
awareness raising they waste money all
over the place they don't research and
they sue or the charities
there are disgusting organized
absolutely horrendous so we send my yeah
you can send rate money to a local
Research Hospital you'd be surprised and
hopeful I can be you can donate directly
to your local research hospital look up
la like I would if it's me just LA
cancer boom here's me yelling that will
be a there will be a link to donate to
them like that one going directly
towards the fight you've got these huge
organizations like American cancer
cancer society Society or whatever and
I'm like if I give them five thousand
bucks what where's it go where's that
money going yeah it's always good to
look on Charity Navigator you know it's
a very good site for figuring out where
the money is going and look at the
breakdown look at how much is going to
research versus administrative cost
versus awareness should be gonna
research right awareness for some
counselors it's quite know about cancer
yeah people they do don't aware yeah
there's still some things that would be
good I would like to see there be a
bigger push to get there for younger men
especially when they have symptoms to go
and get checked this is what I said when
I first got diagnosed I you know I had
colon cancer it's embarrassing you don't
want to do it at this age nobody thinks
they've got talking backstage it's like
in America they don't even recommend you
get a finger up the ass until you're
like 50/50 now that wonderful experience
are like 28 or whatever but ultimately
yeah it's [ __ ] embarrassing you know
it's more embarrassing dying that's
pretty shitty yeah [ __ ] yourself
when you die maybe some do though some
people even do it well it's yeah but
ultimately people have to take their own
health seriously and if they see
symptoms for the love of God please
please if it's nothing [ __ ] celebrate
the fact that it's nothing
sure okay you just went through some
unpleasant [ __ ] you maybe you got a
colonoscopy roll a finger up your eyes
big [ __ ] deal you're gonna have to
have it sooner or later
yeah it's gonna have to happen so you
might as well get it after death yeah
take one I get fingered all day boy hmm
I think it's pretty obvious choice
yeah so I think that's actually really
important and to where is that awareness
yeah I mean check your own house let's
go to the [ __ ] doctor I'm I think
we're all guilty or prolonging we
absolutely are you know it's like but
man you got to take care of your shell
you do ultimately I could have been a
way better position if I had and I
didn't because I was embarrassed right
yeah how long did you have symptoms but
didn't go to the door are you really a
year yeah it's like because there's a
bunch of other explanations for it you
always assume oh it's something else
it's my dad may I ask what symptoms or
is that too personal
I mean I've told people about it you're
in my initial video you know it's we're
talking about [ __ ] like you know we had
cold stool rectal bleeding you know the
kind of thing is like you see blood you
still like oh maybe I just had a you
know a raw steak you know rest ache or
whatever off you rationalize it away
yeah I mean I thought I had IBS I
thought I'd maybe even Crohn's you know
what something like that yeah or
diverticulitis I didn't think I had
colon cancer you know you always assume
it's not cancer it's something L be fine
yeah and then you yeah you prolong any
like you know this is uncomfortable as
define and then you eventually like
alright I'm gonna go find out if I have
Crohn's or what I was like now you have
colon cancer like well that's [ __ ] yeah
I probably should have gone earlier you
know and anybody if you have a symptom
like that don't [ __ ] I can all right
don't yeah it's embarrassing
get over it go to a doctor for the love
of God you know save yourself a [ __ ] ton
of pain later on right is there
something about cancer that like you
came to learn I've been through it that
most people don't know it there's no
feeling of having it like right now if
you asked like do you feel like you have
an illness no I mean that's what's
really talking to my dad like you can't
confront the fact that is so yield
because it doesn't feel it has a really
bad cough when it doesn't it feels it
feels not completely normal yeah I don't
know a vacuum I don't count feel that I
have a tumor in my liver or in my lung
that's that doesn't impact my daily life
you know there's probably some pain
there but you know I'm on painkillers
it's
they just buried there somewhere and the
weird thing is I guess you know people
view cancer as this thing which will be
no turning into a desiccated husk
immediately when you've got it and
completely destroy your life no it
really doesn't
and that's actually scarier mmm cuz you
know you've got a cut on your arm and
it's bleeding you can see I've been
wounded and you have a response to that
you got something inside you that might
be silently eating away at you you don't
you don't even feel it's there and it's
done that pain response no it's
disturbing it's it's insidious and
obviously a lot of it comes down to the
fact you don't feel it before either
you don't feel it before the diagnosis
but you still don't feel afterwards
either you only feel everything around
it you know the side effects of the
chemo the pain from say you know the
fact that I've had an abdominal hernia
for years from the surgery
you know collapsed muscle wall things
like that no no yeah you have to take
painkillers to just manage that and stay
functional mm-hmm
but the actual disease no it's just
there it's invisible mmm that's creepy
as [ __ ] that is [ __ ] weird do you
ever feel like irrationally angry at
your own body for trying to kill you
totally it's like [ __ ] off yeah I think
I was quite healthy like being able to
visualize it as a thing you can fight is
much better than having it be a thing
you don't understand right and a lot of
people do that that's like god it's
recommended even you have an enemy they
identify you have an enemy you can see
you can imagine what it looks like you
can imagine what you have to do to
defeat it versus something you don't
understand spreading throughout your
body without any what you know without
you even noticing and with there being
no solid easy take this pill and you'll
get better option sure that's that's
that's scary I don't think about it that
way though you know I was viewed as the
enemy ever since I got it I view it as
something beatable because it is you
know and every time we get a scan and we
see it's either shrunken or begum like
we're winning you know it seems like
you've been fighting it successfully for
a long time you've beat the odds and it
seems that every
is update it's it's good news or at
least not bad news yeah exactly
you know see at least not bad news is
good you know you know you love that
miraculous remission where it's you see
you coming it's gone
but I'm phases all the reality that
that's probably not going to happen and
you just gotta kind of live with it you
know I know I'm gonna need this
treatment indefinitely do you think that
that kind of uh personifying it as the
enemy is has been one of the keys to
your fighting it successfully I think so
mentally and physically and mentally
such so important it it sounds like a
cliche it's not I know it is 90% mental
because that's what drives everything
else
it drives your ability to fight it
physically it drives your ability to
rehydrate and to want to get better and
to make sure you eat and fuel your body
and all that sort of thing to get up and
not skip that treatment this way it's
like I could not go in because I know
it's gonna hurt you'll be fine
but I'll go in line yeah exactly scared
that's the scary thing you'll feel I'll
skip it and off you're fine yeah and
what if I just skip the next one as well
like that's [ __ ] up mm-hmm but you but
you get up you know get up at 9:00 a.m.
on that Wednesday I go in they do the
blood test I know I'm there get a needle
and they plug it in right there I can
see you know plug it into the port goes
in there stays in there for two days
they rip it out it tastes alien as they
flush it you know to make sure that it's
clean and then you do all over again and
you've got to just keep doing it because
if you tap out on that that's it because
this ain't gonna give up this is gonna
keep trying to kill you mm-hmm
so you have to keep fighting it back you
can't just give it a break is there
something I noticed you saying something
about like you I mean do you appreciate
time in a different way because I
something you said this truck with me is
like I get ten good days and four bad
days and that's enough for me do you
have a different appreciation for time
yeah it was like him you know when we
were talking earlier about would I go
back and you know redo a video will
change the way that I could
those things I think a lot of that came
from that directly it's like I can do a
limited number of videos less than I
used to be able to do I can work less
than I used to be able to do I can play
less than I used to be able to do so
let's make sure that time counts for
something a lot of it is also you assume
at this age you've got wow I've got 50
60 years of the family what if you
didn't well you know you don't know how
long you've got so you know made me want
to try and be a better dad there's no
doubt about that
you know I wanted to connect more with
my stepson and then I have and I've been
doing that I wanted to connect more with
my wife make sure that we get a good you
know we get a good run out of it
I intend to be around when I'm [ __ ]
100 years old
we'll be still bitching about video
games if I can be but sometimes there
might be something outside of my control
you know maybe fighting isn't enough
maybe that's just not enough to keep
going but if that's the case then you've
got to make sure that you spend the time
you've got in the best way you can and
even then it's not like it changes you
overnight like you still want to go
reread it comments you still want to
know it's your people on Twitter like
you can't change your habit of a
lifetime but there's something of the
back of your mind it said do you have
something better to do you know and
maybe that that does change you over
time I think hmm well thanks for sharing
that with us and thanks for spending
your time especially here with us I mean
I really appreciate it
I enjoy it it's great to be out here get
out of here so rarely you know as much
as I love the greenness of North
Carolina
sometimes the smog of LA is a wonderful
place to count right yeah for sure